welcome back to cbs mornings there's a
major new twist in the case of a florida
man who was freed after a federal judge
overturned his murder conviction back in
2018. crossley green is his name he was
convicted in the 1990 killing a 22 year
old man by the name of charles flynn
also known as chip and all he has spent
nearly 32 years behind bars 19 of them
on death row
crossley green went home to his family
last year but now a new ruling could
send the 64 year old man back to prison
48 hours correspondent aaron moriarty
has been covering this case for more
than two decades erin i remember this
story and remember your coverage of it
this is a really surprising twist yeah
and it's a very complex but important
story to tell
costly green's conviction was overturned
because a federal judge ruled that a
prosecutor had withheld crucial evidence
that actually pointed to another suspect
the victim's ex-girlfriend the state
appealed that though determined to keep
green in prison and now that just may
happen
[Music]
he never did no wrong why is our hearts
got to be broken
all over again for something that he did
not do
crosley green's sister shirley white and
brother o'connor green struggled to make
sense of the court decision that has
shattered their lives we love him we
love him you're deaf
and
we don't want to see him go back in
there
nearly four years after a federal court
overturned greene's conviction a federal
appeals court reinstated it the state of
florida has asked that green bee
returned to prison do you think in a way
that
facing this possibility that he could go
back to prison is almost worse because
he has been home with you that's why
hurts so bad
got him here
you give him to us why take him back
from us
it was just one year ago that green came
home for the first time in 32 years
released because of coveted risks while
the court considered the state's appeal
i feel good
he was greeted by relatives he had never
met and got a taste of freedom that he
had long forgotten how would you
describe this past year your year of
freedom
it's been wonderful it's really been
magnificent in a way
due to the fact that i'm with my family
i'm with my kids
job i mean it's been fantastic green
landed behind bars after he was charged
with the murder of a 22-year-old florida
man charles flynn
flynn's former girlfriend kim halleck
told police
a black man robbed them and then shot
flynn
halleck picked green a local small-time
drug dealer out of this photo lineup
although
i really didn't need a real good look at
him i was really scared there was no
physical evidence tying green to the
crime no fingerprints no weapon no blood
but green was convicted by an all-white
jury in 1990. over the years krause
greene never changed his story insisting
he was at a party when chip flem was
murdered i kidnapped no one i killed no
one i did none of those things and two
sheriff department officers on the scene
that night believe him when brevard
county deputy sheriff mark rixie and
sergeant diane clark arrived flynn was
still alive first words out of his mouth
were
get me out of here
i wanna go home did he mention anything
about an assailant nope no i'm thinking
what the hell is going on here rixie and
clark even told the trial prosecutor of
their concerns at the time he took notes
mark and diane suspect the girl did it
she changed her story a couple of times
but the prosecutor never turned over
those notes to greene's defense team
this is the evidence of innocence that
was hidden
by the prosecutor keith harrison is one
of crosley green's attorneys they can't
just hide that evidence they can't cover
it up they have to disclose it
to the defense in 2018 a federal judge
agreed with the defense and overturned
green's conviction leading to greene's
release last year but the state of
florida appealed that decision and in
march the court of appeals sided with
the state the court decided that the
notes would not have changed the verdict
at trial and ruled that greene shouldn't
even be in federal court because he
failed to exhaust all his claims in
state court first it's a setback for
sure and a setback for justice seth
miller is with the innocence project of
florida i think the thing to take away
from it is that courts
ultimately care more about arbitrary
procedural barriers than they do about
the merits of someone's factual
innocence green's sister shirley points
out that her brother was once offered a
10-year plea deal and that eats at you
now
it eats at me because i was trying to
make him take them 10 years just for him
to be home
but he said i didn't do it and i'm not
going to take it
and then they turn around and give him
all this time greene's attorneys are
asking that he'd be allowed to stay out
on house arrest while they appeal he
intends to spend as much time as he has
with family these are my sons and i love
him
but with the uncertainty of his future
even a simple get-together becomes
emotional
green says he refuses to give up hope
it may take more time for the assistance
just get right but it's going to get
right offensively
you know and you still have faith that
the system is going to get it right
eventually
of course i'm not going to give up my
faith
you know what i'm saying i came too far
to give up my faith look what it look
what it got me look what my faith got me
here again
with you
with my family
you know with friends
i can't
say what gonna happen can't no one say
what's gonna happen
all i do i get up and i pray
you understand what i'm saying
for another day
we reached out to the florida attorney
general's office and it said that
because this is an ongoing case it
cannot comment further at this time oh
boy erin i hope people are watching your
story who can make a difference in this
case it it seems wrong on so many levels
the fact that he was offered a plea deal
and didn't take it speaks volumes to me
because he's always said over the years
i did not kill that young man you know i
don't know how many times he said that
to me but this is a lot of people say
that you know a lot of people say i
didn't do it who have actually done it
but he's offered a chance to get out and
still get a lesser sentence and refuse
to take and the one thing he really
wants is to be retried he has always
said just give me a trial because
he believes then the real truth will
come and it doesn't sound like the
original detectives believe that
they don't they don't um both of them
throughout the years alan said because
they really did believe what the defense
has said that this that there may not
have been an assailant at all that this
wasn't mistaken identity that in fact
the reason why this this young woman may
have
said there was an assailant was to
deflect suspicion off of her i just
can't believe this all comes down to
paperwork really at the end of the day
right we're not even talking about guilt
or innocence procedural issues but that
really is the focus often of a court of
appeals decision it's not they're not
looking back at innocence or guilt
they're looking at whether the
procedures were followed so when will we
know if he's going back within this next
month um
his defense attorneys are asking the
entire 11th circuit to do a rehearing if
six judges say yes then he will stay out
pending that hearing
if he cannot get that re-hearing he will
probably go back to prison and his hope
then at that point is the u.s supreme
court and that's a very yeah based on
what you know about this case what do
you think is going to happen um
i this i really honestly have no idea
what the court will decide i'm hoping
that they do give up re-hearing me too
psychologically very hard to go back
yes aaron thank you very much